"The Pogo Masterpiece"
HAaaHH-ShiitHaheuuuueuuu
I'm gonna DIE ohhh...
BWEEEUGH that wasn't a big juuuuump
Okay can you jump a bit-NOoOoOo
Alright I just need to go forward a lil' bit
HwOOP
That did NOT help me at ALL
In fact, I've gone backwards from where I wanted to AUUUUGH
God dammit
EuUuAGH YeEaAhhhh
Ahh fuck
Hang on- hue-noOOOO
Little bit- little bit HUUUEEUGH
Little BITCH more like it
FUUUDGE
[airhorn mark]
K that's not gonna work
I see the landmine back there but I have a funny feeling that's... CHEATING
WHY DO I NOT GO HIGH?!
How about noOooOoo do the OPPOSITE of that
[breath]
GAGH YOU'RE BACK IN THE SAME PLACE
HAh, how 'bout some-a THIS
SLIIIIDE
I count it, it won, it gave it to me so I'm the best
I'm a ninjaaaa
Habouuuh-ow
You've pinned my head into my butthole-ow
I'm not exactly a very stealthy ninja
I wouldn't even set these off
oWowOwoWoah Hey-ho-HEYY it's a party!
Everybody forget what the hell I was talking about before
[Mark Becoming a car] BuhbuhduhbuhbuhduhbubuhBUHHHH
Hnnng I just wanna take a... relaxing break here
Now that my entire spine has been ejected from my body
And is just used as a-an airline pillow cushion for my neck
Hahbahdahbib- missed me WOahhhh
*sings*  Something tells me I'm NOT gonna surviiiive
Auuurghe right through my neck! Owww
Right this time... Fa I di-I didn't even say nothin'!
I-I wonnn!
Look I'm theeere
Fuck do not go backwards
Can I just-fucking god dammit I got my head stuck in my asss
"Cliff Jump" Hello? oh
SOrry! Er-oh-HI! Eur-Why is everybody on this cliff?!
uuuuhhhhh-SOOOO
*cough*I SAVED you!
You're welcome sir!
We're gonna be pulled up to safety and you can thank my broken pelvis and impaled penor
Hi lil' girl, are you in trouble?
Lemme just.. Lemme just bicycle kick for a lil' bit, I wanna work my core strength
Welp nevermind I guess workout's over
*sings* Sailing into deeath (Mark the majestic singer)
Owwwhowww
Well... Vi-uh victory is mine!
I've done many-a Matrix- EUUGH
Wh-what good were those baaaalls?!
WEURGH take my balls!
"Bottle Run Number One"
This is the first bottle run that has ever been made
And I shall be victo-OH SHIT
... oOpS
Let's try this again..Oh my God
It like-I'm not pushing forward on that, it catapults you
It just- Ekk, oh god nooo
I'm embarrassing myself
*sarcastically* I was the king of bottle runs, didn't ya know
Oh fuckk
Well I made it!
And my bike too!
I'm not missing anything else
Not that I remember
I didn't have anything else important when I started this
EUUUUUGH FUDGE
It's like impossible to get oOoOoOoOoOo
Flyyy aghhh
Ehhh... Hehhh
*Sings in the best note possible* I'm the beESSSSSTTTTTT
Yeeeaaaye
"The Mayhem Mechanics"
"Remember to swing, alert second invasion" wait oh gawd
How do I-oh-oh there we go
HEUGH oh jeez HUEEGH
*laughing* you'll never escape
my pinwheel of death
oh god... you'll never-
you'll never conquer the *laughing* tornado
of destruction, woah Jesus
oh god
[long pause] oh
oh jeez
why is this happening?
why am I here? why am I witness
to this? OH GOD!
*surveying the carnage
oH click here to win?
oh god I didn't need to make
this monument of destruction... I didn't
need to sit on the blood throne I coulda just *victory sound plays*
clicked! ...why did I do that?
sword fight simulator- oh
*surprised gasp* oH! heh-
oh- hEH haha I'ma
stab ya! heh *more forcefully* I'MA STAB YA
wooOOAH it looks like you looost!
kick! This is
Sparta! Oh jesus
*laughing* my leg! ey I- hey could
you give that back buddy? I kinda need it
to kic- oh jesus [break] I'm A
STAB ya! *short laugh* I didn't even need to
stab ya, I didn't stab you at all, you
stabbed yourSELF! [pause] your
SELF! eaugh! eaugh!
eaugh! I'm 'onna headbutt AND
kick ya at the same time I'm gonna scissor your head
in between my hea- my foot and
my face, and it's gonna 'SPLODE
...ow. well,
that leaves me a little defenseless!
oooOOH! [pause] shit
aUGH! Goddamnit I don't wanna ki-
that guys already dead! Leave him
alone! [pause] oh
oh GOD! His butt has become
sentient! eUH, *shouting* look out old man!
LOOK OUT! HE'S CRAZY!
euH GOD! IT'S
LITERALLY THE BUTTSTABBER!
*laughing* It's 100 percent literally
the buttstabber...
eeaahhAUGH! There you go, okay and then
no ground- AAAAH
That helps! okay, okay and then
save my stuff
Ultimate hail lord gabe en
I'm sure thats gonna be good one
but theres a bit button that "do not click
here" *garbled* so we're gonna click it
oh [pause] awwww
*laughing* hohohohoo
Ultimate hella- Hail lorde gaben!
*very loud explosion*
*surprised* GOODBYE WORLD! *nervous laugh* good
byYYEE
Where's my steam sale? [break] cliff jump
t- cliff t- oh! oh its similar!
but not the s- ow
*laughing* well, I'll just rest in this tree for a little bit,
get my bearings before I
once again throw myself from the precipice
hhhEYUP- eh, s'cuse me
sorry, missed me, dick, why is this
solid, heh, missed again!
*victory sound* Looks like once more
[pause] I am the winner of some weird bizarre
cliff diving contest
[break] DUNANUHNAH NUH NUH
*forcefully* I'LL KILL YOU *glass breaking* o-oh
*end music starts playing in the bg* hang on a second... aren't you glad
I just saved you -  from that horrible fall?
op- well, nevermind here comes the
horrible fall... lets hope that eAGH
AUGH! *in an old man voice* YES! YES
MY LEGS DIDNT WORK ANYWAY
OH GOD [pause] YOU
INTERRUPTED THE MIRACLE
MY LEGS WERE MOVING- oh god they still are
wha- why- why- why is
they still are? *end music increases in volume*
This has been
Happy Wheels highlights! Thanks for
watching! If you wanna see more Happy Wheels
right now, check the description or click the annotation
for the full Happy Wheels playlist
AND if you wanna see more Happy Wheels
in the future, PLEASE click the like button
to let me know! Thanks again everyone,
and as always, I WILL
SEE YOU! In the
next video! Buh-bye!!